for decades Richmond California has had
a reputation for violence in 2007 this
city of a hundred thousand people had 47
homicides
it was one of the highest murder rates
in the country the city created the
office of neighborhood safety to
specifically target gun violence by
working directly with those most at risk
by 2012 homicides had fallen from 47 to
[Music]
this is right there on around the corner
of 37th and wall pretty much a boundary
between two neighborhoods did have had
conflict with one another for a really
long time
[Music]
there's been a lot of lives lost in
between those two neighborhoods folks
want to show folks that I'm not to be
messed with don't play with me respect
me at all times because they don't want
to die I thought he liked to keep those
boundaries to keep a separation
[Music]
folks become soldiers without anything
even one too
they're drafted they don't get a choice
[Music]
I had a fellow recently say I've never
grieved without violence
I've had several traumatic violent
experiences and my grieving process has
always included violence
I lost my youngest brother as a result
of gun violence I know what it's like to
feel like the authorities don't have a
clue I know what it's like to hear close
associates to the victim my brother say
to me we know what happened we know who
did it
let's ride I know what it's like to want
to ride
and I know the courage the internal
courage the self fight that is required
to say no
a terrible moment in my life was when my
cousin at urban Kiley got killed he's
from North Richmond made me basically
almost stepped back like and get back
into that life I like if you want to
call it I was looking for answers I
wanted to you know find out what
happened I was to the point that it was
my mind was that whoever did this kind
of pay
Owen s you know they got engaged to
people that the ones we loved ones we
hate the ones we you know so when stuff
happened and they hear a name is like oh
my god that's such and such cousin that
sessions that you know so it was
instantly they pop up pull straight in
front of my car can hide from you know
they came to the front O'Toole
cuz that's when it's really bad at the
front of like watching somebody that you
thought you it's gonna be able to grow
over and you know like I guess we're
thinking too far as you know you know
they're just thinking too far ahead I
guess cuz he somebody cut it short
these people on the street you want them
to know you and you want to know that
more than just just them family members
friends of theirs that makes your job so
much easier and I wonder what the
address of your emergency 15 and
password and it's a group of boys down
the street I think who wasn't have a gun
what's up man depends on your pockets
keep your hands on your pocket your hand
and your pocket along with you weird you
hanging out on the Greenway okay that's
what I did my neighbor hot pants it like
on the Greenway for everybody was with
the guns who would know okay the last
guy you were with a couple months ago I
had a guy who actually lived at this
house oh that way
yeah you know what it is alright okay if
I started telling this I was uh yeah
every fall is just fresh out it's you it
was hard for me to find a point makers
for wine I didn't have a high school
diploma
I was just surviving just doing what I
had to do survive and then they came
along it kind of like gave me a path
we're not baking cats to be a part of
this program you're part of this because
you want something for your life what
we're challenging you all to do at some
point is a sit across the table with a
cat that's from the other side of town I
was waiting for that to come to anyway
you're gonna have to time build some
type of relationship in a way ain't
gotta be a kumbaya a relationship but I
respect you you respect me situation
everybody go get it but the ones that we
can't reach long as they get it that'll
make everybody else realize that it work
it was personal at first books life too
short I've seen so many people drought
made him get shot too many times it's
just amazing that as you just continue
to be with them and this is a four and a
half year relationship with area he goes
to jail if he comes home no judgment
open orders welcome home
he gets shot go to the hospital not what
were you doing out there
it's are you all right and we need to
try to figure out some kind of way to
where this doesn't happen to you again
now I mean he's on his way to a
four-year university try this on for
size first of all being disability
you don't have to go on top because you
rip the code we believe in buying their
young man suits I driven out to this
area a town what to go pick this young
person up and he doesn't have his tie
home because he doesn't know how to tie
it and so I reach over begin tying his
tie and showing him how to you know make
a double Windsor in his tie and when
I've got to tie you and I got him
already
put his jacket on make sure that you
know he was together and I looked over
at his mom she was crying she said my
son looks so good in a suit
he's never worn a suit before and the
only time that I thought I would see my
son in his suit would be in a casket
[Music]
tonight police tell me they have few
leads the killing of the 20 year old
they say the shooting was targeted but
they don't know why the death of his
beloved young man has devastated his
community
so the coroner's office will be in touch
with you guys tomorrow promise promise
promise okay
like I said tonight go to Grandma's or
your house somebody's house before
Miss America has any children
[Music]
folks are tired they're tired of going
the funerals are tired of getting our IP
hats and our IP shirts are tired of
being broke the attitude hasn't changed
the attitude that I'm from here and
you're from over there hasn't changed
the change is you haven't been driving
cars into my neighborhood for a year
ain't nobody been over there for a year
so there's somewhat like a white flag
but it's on velcro it can easily just
get snatched away at any given time and
so that's what we're working on to make
sure that it becomes a permanent white
flag the murder of Lincoln player broken
eight month ceasefire between feuding
neighborhoods and raised fears of
further shootings that I lost I lost to
somebody killer like we know we gonna
open our eyes and say I'm gonna leave it
like like I wanna I wanna I wanna do
something with my life like I'm proud of
the Richmond
[Music]
[Applause]
you want to talk about the significant
drop in crime talk to these young people
when crime goes back up it's not going
to be because the office of neighborhood
safety is not doing our job it's not
gonna be because police are not
arresting people it's that young people
again have decided to support triggers
they control the flow so if they're the
ones who are controlling the flow let's
make sure they know we care about them
not just the officer neighborhood safety
but that the city the community we care
about you in the way we show you that we
care about you is we're willing to
investing
[Music]
I had a job since last year April I'm
starting a new job at Chevron in
Richmond and it feels good it's for a
wonderful man I can't go in there with
no beer it's a good haircut though it's
for the dollars what's hard is bidding
them streets every night trying to
basically fool the police and at the
same time hopefully nobody come get you
hopefully nobody coming over you know
them whore that's hard right there this
what you get into the straight walking
that straight line is easy it's a
straight line you know
[Music]
are they gonna identify you know what if
they do so there would be no
fingerprints or anything like that